we've basically nationalized the banks
and that's one way to think about it the
private part of the financial sector has
just shrunk dramatically and the
regulated part of the financial sector
has just gone up dramatically and we'll
just we'll see that over the next
several months and years another villain
that's been blamed I guess and this is
coming from the highest uh echelons of
government including Biden himself is
the concept or is deregulation basically
that back during the Trump era uh the
the the assets mix that the big Banks
had to hold did not apply to the smaller
and mid-sized Banks and we're going to
just play a clip of Biden here in a
second um talking about uh the role that
he thinks that played and I'd like to
get both of your response to the idea
that um deregulation
weakening.front rank is what led to this
problem during the Obama Biden
Administration we put in place tough
requirements on banks like Silicon
Valley Bank and Signature Bank including
the Dodd-Frank law to make sure that the
crisis we saw in 2008 would not happen
again
unfortunately the last Administration
rolled back some of these requirements
I'm going to ask Congress and the
banking Regulators to strengthen the
rules for banks to make it less likely
this kind of bag failure would happen
again under Dodd-Frank banks that had
over 50 billion dollars in assets were
regulated differently than banks that
had under 50 billion dollars
and
he he mentions Trump and everyone
mentions Trump but actually it was a
bipartisan decision in Congress because
Congress was bribed you know you know
both parties were bribed
to exempt to raise that from 50 billion
to 250 billion having said that we don't
know whether
regulating them differently would have
produced a different result
that's what no one has filled in and I
don't see any reason why that's true
there was nothing nothing to stop
Regulators from coming in
and
getting
Silicon Valley Bank to change its
behavior in fact the the rapid growth of
Silicon Valley Bank was the reddest red
flag a regulator could ever see so there
was just and and they could see the
balance sheet there was nothing stopping
them you can't just wave your hands and
say deregulation there was deregulation
they had the power the knowledge they
could have done it
conversely if it had been in the 250
billion dollar category The Regulators
could let them go I mean if they let
them go as they stood they could have
let them go at 250 billion there's just
so that's what's demagogic about blaming
deregulation there was enough discretion
either above the 250 billion dollar
level or below it to make whatever make
whatever decision they wanted and they
made they didn't make the best decision
here I want to bring up this this uh
chart uh from the Board of Governors and
the treasury and uh all of our slides by
the way are linked uh below if anyone
wants to see the the data we're using
here but
um it's got several lines here and you
can see a sort of unprecedented at least
in this snapshot here situation where
the Blue Line the federal debt to GDP
ratio is you know higher higher than
ever
um the that's you know new territory
here at the same time the FED is trying
to tame inflation which is the green
line you see it spiking up down there
and uh using thing higher interest rates
which is the red line
um also you know obviously on an upward
trajectory so given this what looks to
me like a rather unprecedented situation
where do both of you expect this is all
headed the 1970s when you look at that
inflation Dynamic even though there was
a deficit problem a lot of it was from
very high levels of Bank lending that
was our fastest pace of Bank lending in
in U.S history and that really coincided
with with uh you know people that were
born and you know the baby boomer
generation entering their home buying
years and so you had that surge of
demand at the same time as you had
obviously the oil supply constraints and
so a lot of the there's more money
creation from Bank lending than there
was from fiscal deficits whereas if you
look back further to 1940s uh that was
an equally as inflationary decade and
there's very little Bank lending it was
almost entirely a physical driven
phenomenon the basically massive
deficits to fight the war were highly
inflationary
and the current environment we find
ourselves in the 2020s in many ways is
more similar to 1940s which is the vast
majority of the money creation and the
inflation was not because of excessive
Bank lending I mean Bank lending levels
are pretty normal and almost all of it
was from unusually large physical
deficits that we'd not seen since World
War II as a percentage of GDP and I also
I don't really see a realistic path to
cutting that anytime soon because you
have social security Medicare that's
very popular programs
um uh it's just it's it's you know kind
of that third rail that that politicians
don't want to touch
um we have military spending you know we
have 750 foreign military bases over 800
billion a year on that but especially
what's going on geopolitically it's it's
you know that's not likely to be cut
anytime soon
um and also then you have a lot of
politicians that some of them do want to
raise taxes other ones don't uh it seems
like there's a enough of a mix that it's
it's taxes are unlikely to go up
materially
and so I think that you know we look at
the 1970s they because debt the GDP was
so low one of the things they were able
to do was sharply raise rates to try to
bring down Bank lending get the positive
real rates
um and that helped get inflation under
control whereas 1940s because you had
over 100 debt the GDP
um it was very hard to raise rates and
so instead they just kept rates low
despite High inflation and anyone
holding dollars bonds uh and things like
that really got devalued on an ongoing
basis and so I think that unfortunately
2020s are kind of shaping up in that
direction
where you know they might get the
positive real yields for brief periods
of time uh especially if they you know
they're willing to cause a recession to
do it but I think the majority of the
decade probably is just going to be have
a tough time getting inflation under
control because I don't think they're
going to get the deficits under control
and I also don't think that interest
rates are going to be high enough to
compensate people for it
have a nice day yes our closing messages
hold on to your hats folks hey thanks
for watching that excerpt from my
conversation with Lynn Alden and Arnold
cling about the Silicon Valley Bank
meltdown and what caused it who's to
blame what to expect next for the U.S
banking sector uh you can watch the full
conversation by clicking here or on the
link in the description below and
subscribe to reason TV and watch these
conversations live every Thursday at 1
pm Eastern